[Musik]
das Denkmal des ukrainischen
Nationaldichters tarastschiffchenko im
Zentrum von borodianca ist zum Sinnbild
des Krieges geworden von russischen
Angriffen schwer zerstört doch nicht vom
Sockel gefallen obwohl viele Häuser in
Trümmern liegen immer mehr Menschen
kehren zurück das Leben soll weitergehen
wir haben uns mit Christian langehenke
verabredet er arbeitet für UNICEF das
Kinderhilfswerk der Vereinten Nationen
lastet Nothilfe in der Ukraine und
unterstützt den Wiederaufbau zerstörter
Häuser jetzt da der Winter bevorsteht
versuchen sie noch so viele Gebäude wie
möglich zu reparieren die Hochhäuser im
Zentrum von bordianka sind verloren zu
weitreichend die Zerstörung lange Henke
konzentriert sich vor allem auf
Einfamilienhäuser am Rande der Stadt
unser Ziel ist es so viele Häuser wie
möglich einfach zu reparieren also das
heißt so viele Dächer so viele Fenster
so viele auch diese collective Center
einfach zu reparieren so dass die Leute
erstmal über den Winter kommen dann auch
sozusagen
verteilen können das ist erstmal so viel
wie möglich
8.200 Häuser sollen noch bis Ende des
Jahres fertiggestellt werden es ist ein
Wettlauf gegen die Zeit
Christian langehenke nimmt uns mit zu
einer Familie deren Haus gerade
repariert wurde das Dach wurde zerstört
auch viele Fenster
Valentina bulgarco war zeigt uns das
Ergebnis der Arbeit sie ist dankbar für
die Unterstützung
jetzt wo das Dach gemacht ist können wir
alles abschließen Gott sei Dank
doch die Gasleitungen sind nach wie vor
beschädigt wie wird sie über den Winter
kommen
wir werden das Wasser in Eimern heiß
machen das ist kein großes Ding wir
werden wenn es nötig ist in unseren
Kleidern schlafen es wird ja nicht für
immer andauern es wird schon klappen
Valentinas fünfjährige Enkelin Milana
ist zu Besuch sie hat bei der Großmutter
übernachtet auch sie hat die Angriffe
der Russen erlebt seitdem hat sie Angst
vor Fremden doch die alte Dame möchte
ihrem Enkelkind beibringen trotz aller
Katastrophen positiv in die Zukunft zu
blicken alles soll wieder aufgebaut
werden
wird noch schöner als zuvor
die Menschen werden sich verändern alles
wird sich ändern es wird wieder junge
Leute hier geben und ich denke am Ende
wird alles gut werden
Vertrauen in Gott in die Regierung die
eigenen Fähigkeiten viele Menschen die
zurückgeblieben sind vereint die
Hoffnung
angesichts der vielen Häuser die in den
Straßen der umliegenden Dörfer noch
immer in Trümmern liegen erstaunlich und
doch irgendwie typisch für dieses Land
der Überlebenskünstler
in Ihrem Garten treffe ich vira clukun
die ganz allein zurückgeblieben ist ihre
erwachsenen Kinder sind mit den Enkeln
nach Polen geflohen in Sicherheit schon
vor dem Krieg hat sie von Obst und
Gemüse gelebt dass sie selbst anbaut
auch deshalb wollte vira glukun ihr Haus
nicht verlassen trotz der Gefahr ihr
Haus ist alles was sie hat und so blieb
sie selbst als die Russen in ihr
dorf-starabuda einmarschierten und auf
die Häuser schossen sie erinnert sich
noch genau an die Angst
zum Glück lag ich auf dem Fußboden als
sie mit ihren Autos vorbeifuhren mit
ihren Maschinengewehren sechs Mal haben
sie geschossen
bulimiotum
ist vieles zerstört die 56-Jährige will
aber alles wieder aufbauen
doch es geht langsam es fehlt an Geld
für Materialien vor dem Winter hat sie
zumindest die Fenster abgedichtet
wie der Winter für mich wird was soll
ich Ihnen sagen wenn die Leute von der
UN uns helfen dann kann ich das Dach
reparieren und der Winter wird okay für
mich es wird warm einige Menschen haben
mir Feuerholz gebracht ich zahle das
langsam zurück
die Hilfsbereitschaft sei gewachsen
angesichts der Not das erzählen uns
viele Menschen in den Dörfern rund um
borodianca weil die Gasleitungen
weitgehend zerstört sind sammeln viele
Holz im nahegelegenen Wald
bonjoikas die traditionellen Öfen mit
denen man früher heizte haben
Hochkonjunktur auf der Dorfstraße direkt
gegenüber viras Haus hat der Nachbar
zehn Stück zusammengelegt die hat er mit
seinen Freunden selbst
zusammengeschweißt sie sollen nun an die
Soldaten an der Front gehen
das ist ein kleines Ding unsere Gabel es
ist nicht viel das verstehen wir aber
wir haben uns entschieden dass wir damit
ein bisschen helfen können
jeder einzelne Ofen wird noch einmal
geprüft Dima zeigt mir wie die bonjoikas
funktionieren mit Holz dass sie aus den
Wäldern geholt haben
sie geben das den Soldaten
hier können Sie Essen aufwärmen oder
ihre Kleider trocknen das ist warm
wenig später kommen die Soldaten um die
Öfen abzuholen zehn Stück sind es Ruslan
und Dima versprechen sie werden noch
weitere herstellen so schnell wie
möglich in den Schützengräben und an den
unzähligen Checkpoints überall im Land
werden die Öfen dringend gebraucht denn
sie alle sind überzeugt der Krieg wird
in diesem Winter nicht enden
was die Ukrainer im Moment durchmachen
und erleiden das lässt sich nur schwer
nachvollziehen ihre einzige Hoffnung
liegt im Glauben an einen Sieg der
Ukraine gegen Russland welche Rolle
spielt dabei ihr Präsident wo Leute mir
selenski wie erlebt er diesen Krieg das
habe ich ihn gefragt im Interview in
Kiew
alle Beiträge aus unserer Doku haben wir
noch mal für euch verlinkt in der ZDF
Mediathek das findet ihr hier
auch wenn in der Welt momentan viel los
ist verliert nicht das aus dem Blick was
geschieht abonniert unseren Kanal